[Music]
where are you from I'm an American
journalist I came here as a special
correspondent and what about you I'm
here a lot
we have 45 minutes till the bar closes
long enough to get swacked
[Music]
should we meet again
again and again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here on a charitable course please
don't go into detail
[Music]
who's that friend of yours would I do
interesting
he's waiting for you outside of the
hotel right now
this country is kind of like a gambler's
Paradise
everybody's giving the odds a shake
whichever game they feel like playing
your British friend interests me
how long have you known him how do you
know who he is who he says he is I could
just snap my fingers and envelope of
twenty thousand dollars in your lap like
that
did you know the Department of Defense
is after you
do you know how many people are playing
in your game a lot of people are
involved
what did you do things aren't as simple
here as you want to think
[Music]
you're gonna get us both killed
what part of your hand what are you
Moses
I wanted to know the exact dimensions of
Hell
[Music]